my name is Emily to pander and i
graduated in 2013 from paideia Christian
school I was home-schooled and grew up
in Los Gatos California and I'm now a
politics major at Hillsdale College and
in spending this semester in Washington
DC as a part of the Washington Hillsdale
internship program and I'm interning
with Congressman Tom McClintock on
Capitol Hill the Washington Hillsdale
internship program we call whip for
short we bring anywhere between 10 to 20
students a semester out to DC they take
two or three classes and they in turn on
the hill at the Heritage Foundation
really anywhere they want to we find
somebody coming out of college who has
some practical real-world experience
especially experience that applies to
what we do it really sets them apart
Washington is one of those places that
kids can learn a lot and gain a lot just
from being here for a few months and
that sense coming here and having that
internship experience i can guarantee
will be life-changing
you